well let's get more now on Eddie Jones
being sacked as head coach of England's
rugby team joining us live from
Twickenham sky sports reporter Eleanor
Roper Eleanor why did he have to go
yeah I mean this has just been confirmed
in the last couple of minutes by the rfu
that Eddie Jones after seven years has
been sacked as the England coach now the
rfu was holding a review following this
year's Autumn Nation Series where
England won just one out of their four
fixtures Jones been in charge since 2015
so seven years at the helm and everyone
gearing ahead to next year's Rugby World
Cup so it's a massive massive 12 months
for English rugby but the results just
weren't in his favor this year England
have had two poor Six Nations they then
traveled this summer to Australia where
they did get a series win and it felt
like Jones was bringing on some younger
exciting players but heading into this
awesome they lost their opening fixture
to Argentina they drew with Japan they
beat Japan Drew with New Zealand but it
was the Lost of world champion South
Africa that proved decisive the rfu here
at Twickenham then deciding to hold a
review into what had happened and
ultimately deciding to part way with
Eddie Jones now this is a real sort of
deviation in their plans he's all is a
person that England had backed to take
them through to next year's World Cup he
was always going to leave after the
World Cup next year so there had been
succession planning going on here
uh with with plans to announce in May
who would take over but that's obviously
now been brought forward what a
statement here which has just come in
from the rfu saying it's important to
recognize the huge contribution that
Eddie Jones has made to English rugby
winning three six nations championships
including a grand slam back in 2016. he
also you may remember LED England to a
Rugby World Cup Final in Japan where
they lost to South Africa you know he's
got a huge experience on the
international stage and he has done an
awful lot for English rugby but today
the rfu announcing that they are parting
ways with him as yet no no announcement
on who will take long-term charge but
they are saying that Richard Cockrell
who's one of Eddie's assistant coaches
will take take charge of the day-to-day
running of England rugby for the time
being so plenty more to come on this
story
Eleanor thanks very much